stephen harper a rappelé à plusieurs
occasions dans les cinq dernières années
les efforts de son gouvernement pour
protéger les enfants contre les
cyberprédateurs un rapport du ministère
de la sécurité publique obtenue par la
sib ici conclut que la stratégie
nationale de lutte contre l'exploitation
des enfants portent fruits qu'elle a
permis de sensibiliser les canadiens le
nombre d'arrestations a aussi augmenté
mais des retards importants dans le
traitement de ces dossiers de
pornographie juvénile persiste une des
raisons pour expliquer cette situation
les gers et a retenu une partie des
fonds que lui alloue le gouvernement
fédéral pour contrer ce genre de crime
afin d'aider entre autres le
gouvernement à équilibrer son budget
entre 2008 et 2013 les gers et n'a pas
utilisé en moyenne le quart de son
budget de lutte contre l'exploitation
des enfants ces deux millions de dollars
par année un total de 10 millions en
cinq ans soit
le résultat c'est que des sommes prévues
pour contrer un problème grave ne sont
pas utilisés affirme le député
néo-démocrate l'exploitation des enfants
sur internet est un problème qui prend
de l'ampleur de façon exponentielle
conclut le rapport de la sécurité
publique le nombre de plaintes a cheminé
au site web si bear head a explosé
passant d'environ 5000 6 en 2008 à 26
mille cinq cent en 2013
nous savons que les policiers sont
débordés et que le traitement de ces
dossiers de pornographie juvénile accuse
un important retard affirme signy
arnason de cyberaide une porte parole du
ministère de la sécurité publique
affirme que la grc n'a effectivement pas
dépenser tout l'argent alloué pour
protéger les enfants des cyberprédateurs
une situation qui serait attribuable à
des problèmes de recrutement de
personnel qualifié ici philippe leblanc
radio canada montréal